Hey, Jack! Sorry I'm so late.
You're not. I changed the clock on your phone, I just got here.
Anyway, I really appreciate you coming to my neighborhood,...
...my home turf, if you will.
I see. Well played, Jack.
You anticipated my countermove, employing a "shortness is weakness" power axiom.
However, I knew then you might know...
...that I knew to bring my own furniture, so I also brought my Jack Welch power pillow.
I'm very sorry, sir.
I thought you might do that,...
...which is why I'm going to be the first person to do "power quiet talking,"...
...forcing you to lean in and wonder if you're missing any key phrases, like an idiot.
I thought you'd try "power quiet talking," which is why I'm wearing a hearing aid.
Still me, I'm everything I hoped I'd be.
Let's begin.
Two percent raise, a show on Christmas,...
...no gross merchandising and you have a run in your stocking.
Eight percent raise, two weeks off at Christmas,...
...five gross, and nice try, I'm not wearing stockings.
That's a vein.
No raise, no vacation,...
...and from now on, you have to say "Go for Liz!" when you answer your phone.
Hold on a sec.
Come on, lemon! I'm just doing the Sorcerer's Apprentice.
You respond with a pirate holiday...
...and I have no choice but to play the hillbilly auction.
It's all in the tapes.